changes to the travel list have caused
huge frustration this summer but how
exactly are the decisions made well it's
assessed by a body called the joint
biosecurity center or the jbc it looks
at over 250 countries and territories
everywhere is assumed to be amber unless
there's evidence to suggest otherwise
the first stage is this variant
assessment it includes keeping tabs on
the transmissibility of strains and
whether they're vaccine resistant
secondly each country is triaged
assessed on set criteria and while that
does include a look at case numbers
they're also looking at things like
testing rates and whether a country has
the capacity to identify variants using
genomic sequencing and finally those
countries which emerge as contenders for
switching are given a more comprehensive
risk assessment then ministers make the
final decision
so there's a lot more going on than just
a look at straight case numbers and this
is partly why this shows the proportion
of positive cases to tests taken it
shows the situation in mexico and
pakistan they were both on the red list
and in both of those countries the pure
case numbers are actually lower than
they are here but that's because they're
testing proportionally fewer people
india and the uae it's worth noting
those two lines below the uk they were
downgraded to amber and those
proportions will certainly have helped
now keeping new variants out is
absolutely key this shows how in the uk
and in germany the delta variant the
light blue bit is totally dominant while
in france and spain the beta variant
that's the one which may have some
vaccine resistance has solid footholds
partly explains why germany has been
upgraded and france and spain haven't
been
in fact when it comes to variants what
we don't know is every bit as important
as what we do know the uk has some of
the best genomic sequencing in the world
as you can see we're testing for
variants far more frequently than our
european neighbors and finally i want to
leave you with this this shows just how
much we don't know there's been some
contention over why india is now amber
while pakistan remains red well pakistan
only tested genomes in 19 cases in the
most recent two weeks we have data for
19 cases in the whole country if a new
variant was taking hold authorities
would know little about it it shows how
these decisions are ultimately a complex
balance of risks